en france ces violences la nuit dernière
argent' des échauffourées à la suite de
la mort d'un jeune homme à moto dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche le parquet de
pontoise affirmant que les policiers ne
poursuivait pas le jeune homme mais la
famille et les proches de sabri accusent
les forces de l'ordre présentes sur
place d'être en cause dans l'accident
nicolas a vu clair avec thomas bonnet
ils se sont rendus sur place
c'est une famille meurtrie qui nous a
ouvert ses portes
les proches du jeune sabri décédé à
l'âge de 18 ans rift une peine immense
ils souhaitent comprendre ce qui a pu se
passer ce soir là c'est pas écrire comme
ça mais j'en suis sûr
donc voilà je connais tu qu'est ce qui
s'est passé moi ce que je demande - moi
je sais pas qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce
que je sais c'est que j'ai perdu
beaucoup à mon fils elle sait les chefs
et les chefs s'annonce un amour je vais
perdre et je fais confiance à la justice
à la loi voilà j'attends la réponse ne
voit là la mort de ce jeune homme décrit
comme souriant et sans histoires
bouleverse les habitants de ce quartier
d'argenteuil ce qui accentue cette
émotion c'est le flou qui entoure les
circonstances de la mort du jeune homme
les faits se sont déroulés dans la nuit
de samedi à dimanche dans un quartier
pavillonnaire de la ville à bord d'une
moto sans casque sabri a perdu la vie au
moment des faits une voiture de la
brigade anticriminalité est présente
près des lieux mais selon les éléments
dévoilés ce lundi par le parquet de
pontoise le jeune motocycliste n'étaient
pas poursuivis par la voiture de police
présentes à proximité
une version que réfute les proches de
sabri sabre et aurait percuté
ce poteau voiture et il serait mort à
l'hôpital
nous on n'y croit pas du tout on ne
croit pas du tout certains voisins
auraient entendu un bruit pare chocs
nous on est persuadé que c'est une
bavure
et voilà on veut juste que justice soit
faite
dans le quartier où vivait sabri la
colère est forte mais face aux images de
violences qui ont émaillé la commune
d'argenteuil
la famille du jeune homme appelle au
calme et à l'apaisement deux avocates
ont été choisis pour s'occuper du
dossier
une marche en mémoire de sabri aura lieu
mercredi à 15 heures dans la ville
d'argenteuil et pour en parler nous
sommes avec christophe crépin porte
parole du syndicat france police bonsoir
christophe créé par merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france deux
versions d'un accident de la route qui
s'opposent comme souvent dans ce genre
d'affaires c'est inéluctable
systématiquement contre lille il ya une
problématique
déjà c'est très triste la mort de ce
jeune homme est très triste et
systématiquement mes collègues font
preuve de la présomption de culpabilité
pendant que d'après les premières
constatations il n'y a eu aucun contrôle
ni aucun choc avec la voiture de police
donc on va attendre les résultats de
l'enquêté
et on va bien voir comment ça se passe
mais rien ne peut justifier de telles
violences urbaines dans un quartier
suite à la mort de ce jeune homme alors
que sait-on exactement de cet accident
pour l'heure qui a coûté la vie comme on
dit à ce jeune homme on sait qu'il
circulait avec une moto cross que il a
perdu le contrôle de son véhicule qui
est venu s'encastrer malheureusement
dans un poteau téléphonique en ciment et
suite au choc il a été transporté à
l'hôpital où il est décédé
je comprends très bien le deuil de cette
famille je comprends très bien écrit
également le fait que ces gens veulent
savoir et c'est normal quand on perd
approche comme ça surtout à un jeune de
18 ans c'est triste mais rien ne peut
justifier de telles violences urbaines
argenteuil d'ailleurs la famille et nous
mêmes nous nous vendons que toussaint
cesse alors le parquet de pontoise un
écarte à ce jour l'hypothèse d'un
contact vous l'avez dit
même entre la moto et la voiture de la
bac est ce que ce n'est pas trop tôt
pour retirer ce genre de bilan est ce
qu'il ya une enquête sérieuse se fait
larguer deux ans qui a été la première à
administrative
le deuxième judiciaire systématiquement
pour les fonctionnaires sont rentrés au
service on a pu déterminer qui a pas eu
de choc avec le véhicule administratif
ça c'est une chose
et deuxièmement le parquet a ouvert une
enquête et il a fait au maximum
rapidement pour pouvoir déterminer si
les fonctionnaires peuvent être
incriminé ou non est a priori les
résultats du parquet sont claires et
nettes
faut-il craindre selon vous de nouvelles
tensions vont en tant que policier
voulait craignais on sait déjà que c'est
extrêmement tendue sur le terrain
notamment pendant la période de
confinement elle a beaucoup parlé ici
alors tu te fais pendant la paire de
confinement on a eu beaucoup de mérite
urbaine systématiquement dès qu'il y
avait une petite chose ça partait tout
de suite tout de suite en exactions des
banlieues entières s'enflammer là
j'espère qu argenteuil vince calmer
parce que rien ne pourra faire ramener
le jeune homme et moi j'en appelle à une
chose qui est très importante c'est que
systématiquement mes collègues sont
vraiment bénéficié de la suspicion de
suspicion et de la présomption de
culpabilité non pas d'innocence est ce
que vous pensez justement que ces
tensions font suite également à celles
qui se sont déroulées à villeneuve la
garenne également après un accident de
moto en quelque sorte la tension est
prouvée sur une moto qu'il n'avait pas
circulé les gens appellent la police
les legends est excédé par le bruit par
les nuisances appelle mes collègues mes
collègues et celle de procéder à une
interpellation
et quand ils vont pour procéder à
l'interpellation ce jeune homme vers
s'encastrer dans une dans une espèce de
brebis en béton il essaye de le porter
secours étaient systématiquement sa part
tout de suite en présomption de
culpabilité
comment justement vous expliquer cela
vous en avait parlé en début de cette
interview une femme de présomption de
culpabilité il y aurait les bons d'un
côté les méchants de l'autre on imagine
que c'est évidemment beaucoup plus
complexe que cela
ne riez pas débout il n'ya pas de
méchants il ya des gens qui vivent dans
des banlieues et des gens qui veulent
vivre correctement
et puis l initiateur et des gens qui
sont là pour créer des nuisances il ya
des gens qui vont qui qui essayent de
sortir des banlieues pour en faire des
belles choses et je pense que les
violences urbaines que kiki qui font
jour aujourd'hui ne peuvent rien
apporter surtout danser dans cette
situation qui est très difficile
aujourd'hui clairement christophe crépin
au sein de votre syndicat quelles
seraient les solutions les idées que
vous souhaiteriez apporter pour apaiser
les tensions constamment sur le terrain
qui doivent être compliqué pour les
policiers on imagine aussi déjà il est
ben et nous personnellement on
s'explique toujours avec secrétaire
l'été avec le mystérieux où il ya un
fait des propositions ces provisions
n'ont jamais encore pour l'instant été
suivies d'effet je pense qu'il faut rien
laisser passer
et il faut essayer de renouer le lien
entre la population qui habite dans ces
banlieues qui elle rend au respect et
les individus qui crée des nuisances
merci beaucoup christophe crépin porte
parole du syndicat france police d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
après ces nouvelles tensions la nuit
dernière à argenteuil